[Musique]
le 2 mars
1990 monsieur matsnef un écrivain
célèbre et adulé et invité une fois de
plus à l'émission littéraire de Bernard
Pivot
apostrophe Bernard Pivot va introduire
son invité et va vanter les exploits
sexuels de Monsieur
matsnef avec des lycéennes et des
minettes les autres invités vont sourire
de ces
grivoiseries vont parler du talent du
génie de Monsieur
matsnef une certaine Denise Bombardier
qui était aussi invitée écrivaine
canadienne va lâcher une bombe forcément
elle va dire
monsieur matsnef sodomise des fillettes
de 14 ans et s'en vente dans ses livres
c'est
pitoyable choc et consternation en
direct à la télévision les autres
invités tout de suite vont reprocher à
Denise Bombardier d'être une
moralisatrice rétrograde une ennemie de
la liberté oh mon dieu il y en aura même
plus tard pour dire qu'elle était mal
baisée pourtant qu'est-ce qui est
choquant
les paroles de Madame bombardier ou les
actes de Monsieur matsneev savons tous
la réponse à cette question qu'est-ce
qui s'est
passé on appelle ça l'ignorance
collective tout le monde savait que ce
que Monsieur matsnev faisait à des
enfants était
mal mais personne ne le
disait donc tout le monde pensait que
tout le monde pensait que c é normal et
donc personne ne parlait on va passer
pour un idiot si si on est le seul à le
penser ce soir-là ce que Denise
Bombardier a fait c'est casser ce tabou
ce silence et en faisant ça elle a
arrêté la carrière d'un prédateur oser
parler franchement sauve des vies alors
ce
soir je vous invite à faire un truc
extraordinaire on va oser se parler
franchement on va sauver des
vies donc sachez que nous les Suisses
ici
présents nous avons démocratiquement
puisque nous sommes en démocratie
décider de rester dans le Traité sur la
charte de l'énergie qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça bah c'est simple c'est un
traité qui permet à des entreprises
d'énergie fossile de poursuivre des
états si leur législation
environnementale nuisent à leurs
intérêts par exemple il y a assez
récemment 2 ans je crois l'Italie a été
condamné à verser 190 millions d'euros à
une entreprise pétrolière anglaise
pourquoi l'Italie avait démocratiquement
décidé d' d'interdire les forages
pétroliers dans l'Adriatique quelle
horreur c'est comme ça que nous avons
choisi de contribuer à l'effort
international pour arrêter la
catastrophe
climatique c'est pas terrible j'admets
mais on vient de voter une loi climat
vous me direz c'est vrai et c'est même
très très
bien mais l'évaluation de cette loi
climat de nos politiques de nos actions
de consommation indique que ce que nous
avons choisi c'est un
futur dans lequel la température moyenne
de la Terre va monter jusqu'à plus 3
degr à la fin du siècle plus 3 degr par
rapport à ce qu'elle était avant l'ère
industrielle ça a l'air peu mais c'est
beaucoup à Paris avec tous les autres
pays de la terre nous nous étions engagé
à rester à 1,5 c'est un beau dépassement
de
promesse
alors on va se parler
franchement il y a quelques jours à la
maternité de Fribourg une petite fille
est née elle s'appelle
Chloé là on la voit come on est tous ici
présents des gens bien qui trouvont que
faire du mal aux enfants c'est mal je
vous propose de accueillir Chloé dans le
monde que nous avons décidé de
construire pour
elle pour pouvoir le faire bien je vais
être votre porte-parole et lui dire
franchement le monde que nous lui
chère
Chloé bienvenue dans le monde que nous
te
construisons tu n'as pas encore de voix
mais tu as tout l'avenir devant
toi tu es né à la fin d'un été
surnaturel il y a eu plus d'inondations
d'incendie d'ouragans de tempêt que je
ne saurais les compter pour quelqu'un
comme moi qui est né le siècle passé
c'est assez
effrayant pour toi ce sera le meilleur
que tu connaîtras de toute ta
vie quand tu auras 7
ans nous aurons déjà atteint ces fameux
1,5 degrés que nous avions promis de ne
pas
dépasser à ce moment-là la glace du
Groenland va fondre pour toujours c'est
irréversible ça veut dire que la mer va
monter pour des milliers d'années sans
jamais
s'arrêter toi tu n'as que 7 ans tu es
trop jeune pour t'en préoccuper pour
même le
savoir quand tu auras 18 ans nous serons
déjà à + 2
degrés à ce niveau de réchauffement tous
les corau sont
morts à ce niveau de réchauffement on va
assister à des fontes abruptes du
permafrost dans le cercle polaire ça va
dégager du méthane on sait pas calculer
on sait pas combien on sait pas l'impact
mais ça se passera on le sait à ce
moment-là quand tu auras 18
ans les spécialistes prédisent qu'on
devrait compter les réfugiés dans le
monde pour des causes climatiques en
centaines de
millions Duric assurance estime même
qu'on peut parler d'un milliard de
réfugiés tu ne peux pas encore
l'imaginer Chloé mais c'est 100 fois la
Suisse qu'on jette sur les routes et sur
les mers ça fera des morts mais on sait
pas dire
combien par contre tu as 18 ans tu as le
droit de vote maintenant tu vas enfin
pouvoir décider de ton avenir avec tes
concitoyens
l'ennui c'est que la fenêtre pour un
avenir durable et vivable pour tous nous
l'avons déjà
fermé tout ce que tu pe essayer de faire
c'est d'essayer d'éviter d'aller
beaucoup plus loin que ce qu'on a
décidé je ne sais pas si tu auras le
courage d'envisager des enfants dans ce
monde
là je ne sais
pas si tu seras terrorisé par l'avenir
qui t'attend alors que tu as à peine 18
ans mais si tu nous en veux je crois que
tu as le droit chè Chloé quand tu auras
mon âge nous serons déjà arrivés au + 3
degrés auquel nous nous sommes engagés
en votant cette loi
climat à + 3°grés je sais pas raconter
combien de catastrophes auront lieu il y
en a trop mais de toute façon tu t'en
ficheras le seul souci que tu auras
c'est que les spécialistes prédisent
qu'à plus 3 degrés l'agriculture ne
s'adaptera pas l'insécurité alimentaire
sera globale c'est assez simple tout le
monde aura
faim j'espère que tu n'auras pas trop
faim j'espère que tu ne connaîtras pas
trop la guerre j'espère que tu pourras
vivre aussi vieille que
moi dis comme ça franchement ça met mal
à l'aise quand même moi je me sens
extrêmement mal à l'aise à dire vrai
j'ai honte je suis mort de honte je suis
mort de honte pourquoi parce que l'ONU à
travers le GC qui regroupe les meilleurs
scientifique du sujet du monde nous a
expliqué avec l'Organisation Mondiale de
la météorologie avec nos propres offices
fédéraux avec les meilleurs
scientifiques de Suisse qui sont venus
l'expliquer à notre Parlement fédéral le
2 mai
2022 que aujourd'hui nous avons les
technologies et la finance pour viser
1,5°r c'est possible si nous voulons le
faire ils ont aussi expliqué avec plus
de détails que j'ai donné à Chloé ce
qu'un monde à + 3°gr
signifie et on nous avant choisi 3
degrés j'ai honte j'ai vraiment
honte après comme vous l'avez entendu je
suis papa j'ai trois enfants je suis
mort de peur
ces enfants mes enfants vont devoir
traverser ça à cause de notre décision
aujourd'hui et je ne pourrai pas les
protéger ils souffriront ils auront peur
ils verront des catastrophes ils verront
des centaines de millions de
morts et je peux rien y
faire j'ai peur j'ai peur vous imaginez
pas et finalement je suis en colère
je suis en colère parce que je veux pas
ça j'ai jamais voulu ça j'ai jamais
choisi ça on m'a ôté la liberté à moi en
tant que père de défendre le futur de
mes
enfants ce futur
là le secrétaire général de l'ONU lui a
trouvé un résumé très simple future
infernal et donc nous avons décidé
ensemble d'envoyer nos enf enfant en
enfer je suis en colère parce que j'ai
pas voulu ça je suis en colère parce
qu'on ne me laissera pas protéger mes
enfants pourquoi pourquoi on en est là
pensez-y 2 secondes pensez à
matsnef si je vous pose la question là
maintenant qui d'entre vous veut envoyer
Chloé en
enfer dans l'enfer que je viens de
décrire en
fait nous sommes pourtant en démocratie
personne ne veut ça et c'est ça qu'on
nous donne c'est ça qu'on nous a fait
voter pourquoi pensez à
manef qui parmi vous en parle qui ose
franchement avec ses enfants avec ses
voisins avec ses élus avec son patron
avec ses employés ose dire franchement
nous sommes en TR envoyer en train
d'envoyer nos enfants en enfer et nous
le savons
personneose
personnose qui parmi vous a peur du
futur que j'ai décrit pour Chloé pour
celui quelqu'un a peur moi je suis mort
de
trouille là personne a peur vous en
ficher quand mêmeant regardez autour de
vous demandez à votre voisin il a peur
aussi c'est normal si l'humanité existe
encore aujourd'hui c'est parce que la
plupart des gens normaux n'aiment
considèr que faire du mal aux enfants
c'est le pire de la
terre on est fabriqué pour aimer nos
enfants les élever et les protéger pour
qu'ils deviennent des
adultes nous sommes presque tous comme
ça il y a statistiquement quelqu'un qui
aime faire du mal aux enfant ok il est
tout seul il y en a peut-être deux mais
la majorité on veut pas
ça mais on en parle pas tout le monde
ici présent vous pensez que votre voisin
n'a pas aussi peur que vous vous tous
ici présents vous pensez que votre
voisin n'est pas prêt à faire les mêmes
efforts que vous en fait tous ici
présent vous avez peur d'en parler parce
que vous pensez que les autres vont vous
dire mais
non et donc on n'en parle pas et comme
on n parle pas pour avoir rencontré
Madame somaruga sur la Place fédérale je
peux vous le dire elle sait pas que vous
avez
peur je lui ai dit mais franchement
madame je suis papa dites-moi ce qu'il
faut faire je vous donne un bras si ça
sauve mes enfants non les Suisses sont
difficiles à embarquer bah essayer
inviter des parents et poser leur la
question
m'a fait ah c'est une bonne idée
elle savait
pas les élus que vous élisez vous
parlent jamais du problème parce qu'il
pensent que vos problèmes les plus
importants sont des
autres quand nous avons voté la loi
climat c'est ce qui s'est passé ils nous
ont proposé ce qu'ils croyaent qu'on
allait pouvoir accepter parce que jamais
ils nous ont dit on est en train de
parler de sauver la vie de vos
enfants
donc moi j'ai vraiment envie de sauver
l'avenir de mes enfant j'ai envie que
Chloé puisse avoir un futur désirable et
autre chose qui ressemble à des ruines
et à la mort alors je vous propose
demain de sauver des vies en osant en
parler franchement
il va falloir qu'on ose en parler
franchement avec notre patron avec nos
employés avec nos collègues avec nos
clients pour qu'on se rende compte qu'en
fait on veut tous sauver nos enfants
sauf les Salau va falloir qu'on en parle
avec nos
voisins
avec notre famille avec nos enfants qui
a pas l'impression qu'on en a rien à
et qu'on les a
abandonné
et il faudra qu'on en parle avec tous
nos élus à la commune au Parlement au
Conseil fédéral leur casser les
pieds alors je sais c'est super
difficile parce qu'effectivement il faut
avoir le courage de se poser là comme
Denise Bombardier et de dire franchement
nous envoyons nos enfants en enfer je le
veux pas ça me fait peur j'ai envie que
ça soit
différent et on a tous peur qu'on nous
reproche d'être un gach fête de Noël un
gâ Bontemps comme Denise Bombardier a
été un gach télévision bah oui des fois
il faut accepter on est des adultes il y
a des choses vilaines il y a des choses
qui sont pas bien et on veut faire
quelque chose donc on va en
parler alors tout simplement c'est pas
grand chose quand on y pense demain
après-demain pour sauver des vies et là
pour pour le coup c'est la vie de Chloé
c'est la vie de beaucoup de gens il va
falloir oser par les
franchement pour Chloé pour mes enfants
qui sont là pour vos enfants à vous vos
petits-enfants vos neveux vos
filleules pour notre propre humanité
osons parler franchement à tout le monde
partout tout
temps c'est à vous
maintenant